I'm recording one second of every day of
my life for the rest of my life
chronologically compiling these one
second
tiny slices of my life into one single
continuous video
until you know I can't record them
anymore
the purpose of this project is one I
hate not remembering things that I've
done in the past there's all these
things that I've done with my life that
I have no recollection of unless someone
brings it up and sometimes I think oh
yeah that's that's something that I you
know did it's also kind of a personal
protest against the culture we have now
where people just are at concerts with
their cell phones out recording the
whole concert I admittedly used to be
that guy a little bit back in the day
and I've decided that the best way for
me to still capture and keep a visual
memory of my life and not be that person
is to just record that one second that
will allow me to trigger that memory of
yeah that concert was amazing I really
loved that concert